make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so it's been a little while since
we covered anything Batman related that
was not the Batman who laughs and so in
this video what I want to do is I want
to start covering the events of
nightmares now nightmares is actually a
really really cool concept
in the the Batman comics initially I
didn't really care anything about it but
I was like you know what I'm gonna curse
the Batman stuff so I'm gonna go back
and read nightmares and see what's up
maybe when the line has changed and it
did it's actually pretty legit now
here's a funny thing
normally I explained things and make it
make sense to you guys in this video I'm
gonna kind of leave you guys hanging a
little bit and there's a reason why well
I like it just like it's crazy so just
bear with me here it's gonna be a little
bit nuts but but there's actually like
there's part one and then there's part
two we're technically gonna jump onto
part two because in reality part one
just kind of its kind of like a closi it
kind of closes off from a different
story right so part one ties into Batman
number 38 Batman rebirth number 38 and
in Batman V verse number 38 there was
this kid named Matthew who had basically
murdered his parents and then started
going through and killing parents and
then blaming it on like Victor Zsasz and
and and two-face and you didn't really
find out into the end what the
motivation was behind it but what you
end up learning is that like when he was
younger his dad always called him Bruce
Wayne and so what he ended up doing was
like calling himself Bruce Wayne now
initially it was just kinda like okay
his parents died and you assumed it was
just a byproduct of trauma right like he
went through a sort of killing other
parents because of the fact that like it
basically drove him nuts when his
parents died and so you kind of assumed
that like somebody else killed his
parents what are the first nightmares
story arc does is it actually show is
that like Matthew killed his parents
because he wanted to become Bruce Wayne
he was basically a crazy kid but it
doesn't really like tie in to the rest
of nightmares and once we get into the
end of the of the whole arc you'll
understand why but what this does is
initially pick up with Batman just kind
of like basically like in a butcher
place essentially like like a
meatpacking plant is it really what it
kind of looks like there's all these
pigs hanging upside down and he's
basically being held captive by
Professor Pig now under normal
circumstances we wouldn't really care
right like we'd be like okay so
professor Pig whatever professor Pig was
a villain who would basically like
kidnap people and then twist and screw
up their minds and turn him into his
henchman and as far as I'm aware by and
large when somebody's warped by
professor Pig
there's really no way to bring them back
and that's one of the reasons why Batman
like kind of starts to freak out to a
degree now the other half of this and
what's kind of cool is you actually get
as this sort of inside look into how
Batman works when he's like facing off
against a villain right because like
this giant place hanging upside down
he's tied up by Professor Pig but he
doesn't know how he got there and he
can't hear professor Pig talk but as he
comes up on him with a without with a
knife like of course he stabs Batman
literally tortures him and just kind of
toys around with him and screws with it
now the reality of this is that in DC
Comics behind the scenes we never really
see what Professor Pig does to people in
order to like turn them into his
henchmen like his dolls basically it's
really what he kind of calls them oh
we've no really seen how that unfolds
this kind of gives us this sort of
introspective look into it and the sense
of like here's what Professor Pig duck
does he just kind of tortures and warps
their minds and screws them up it really
seems to like kind of push them to a
place where they'll do anything to make
the pain stop but the cool thing about
this is Batman of course like breaks
free and he's like okay so he keeps
talking you know like like he's talking
and talking all the time they love to
talk I can use that to my own ends and
literally like going through and kind of
giving himself this pep talk on what he
needs to do on unwitting what light on
how he can escape this situation and
it's kind of interesting because when
you when you look at Batman as a
character is it's almost like in some
ways he seems to operate on autopilot
and what this does is sort of verify
that right like Batman's experience in
fighting criminals is like they all seem
to have the same kind of pattern right
like they all love to talk they all
basically want the same thing you know
they they basically beg for word in
terms of like the crimes that they
commit you know and like you can never
ever ever let them have it
it's always the same thing over and over
and over again they want to commit the
same kind of crimes over and over and
over again it's a repeating pattern now
it is kind of ironic too because like
when you look at that man technically
he's probably the worst superhero out
there because in spite of his efforts in
Gotham like Gotham is actually worse off
now than it was before he was Batman
because now you have all these super
criminals so really Batman's just made
Gotham worse which is I know it's are we
gonna piss off Batman fans but like
probably because they know it's right
and so like it's it's it's kind of wonky
you know when when it when it comes to
this but like you know throwing a knife
through professor Pig basically taking
him out it's like okay like he should be
scared here but like he's not scared why
is he not scared like why is he not
terrified here intern Batman really kind
of muses with his darker side right like
I could kill this guy I could kill him
and be done with it and then Gotham will
be fixed and that's kind of the the
factor when it comes to Batman right
like technically speaking Batman could
fix Gotham City but the reality is that
like all the kernels in Gotham know that
Batman won't kill them right so it's
coming okay I know you won't do what
needs to be done in order to stop me for
being a criminal so I'll just keep being
a criminal right like because what
reason do I have to stop I know your
weak point I know what you're I know the
line you're not willing to cross
and so as long as I stay on the other
side of that line you'll be fine like
everything will be okay I'll go to
Arkham and then I'll be treated for a
little while and then ultimately I'll
end up escaping or leaving or something
like that and I'll go right back out and
I'll do the same thing that I always do
because you're Batman and you're a
half-measure
you don't have the ability to do what it
takes in order to make sure that like
all the criminals are done and that's
kind of the funny thing about this year
to kind of sidetrack from the story for
a second that's kind of the funny thing
about Batman if he really wanted to save
Gotham City he would because sometimes
the only thing you can do is look at it
look at it being out there look at a
person out there and say they're so
incorrigible and so unable to change the
only way to make the world better is to
remove them from the world and there are
people who will be like well no
everybody deserves a second chance you
know I was like well how many chances do
they deserve right like how many
innocent people are you willing to
sacrifice in order to try to make that
person better are you willing to allow
like 20 innocent people to die 30
innocent people like a hundred innocent
people like like how many innocent
people are you willing to let die in
order to try to rehabilitate some person
and that's where Batman gets kind of
that's a word gets kind of wonky is this
like okay I'm Batman and sure the Joker
kills people all the time and like
Harvey two-face kills people all the
time and so does penguin and professor
pig-like warps their minds and turns it
to mush so they can never go back to who
they were before a fate worse than death
if you ask me The Riddler kills people
and like I believe they can be
rehabilitated so I'm going to sacrifice
hundreds and hundreds if not thousands
of people right now and in the future
because gosh golly I really believe that
Joker deserves a second chance like this
this was so crazy about him that's
what's so crazy about Batman Batman is
actually a worst killer did anybody else
in Gotham if only by his inaction and so
so from here like it's kind of wonky
because I'll heat toys with that he's
like well I could kill him and
everything would be okay and in the
middle of this like once he defeats him
he's like professor big jumps up and
then just starts walking and and again
it's it's it's almost kind of like this
crazy insane experience right like it
really is absolute madness because like
this whole thing this this whole entire
comic takes place over the span of maybe
ten minutes and so that's why it's kind
of wild it's because it's like okay like
why do I it like like Batman Catholics
Rhetta says why do I not have any
weapons why can I not hear professor Pig
talk what's going on like where am i how
did I get in here and how do I get out
because technically speaking it's a room
with no doors and so it's like okay like
like this is Wow because of course we're
batman basically tackles them and then
goes to take him out and they're like
tries to beat him up at the same time
that
trying to look for a way to escape from
this place look for a way to like get
out of here you know like what is going
on with all this and so ultimately like
he basically stops right like the whole
conflict stops Batman looks a professor
Pig and he says how do I get out of here
like like how did I get here and how do
I get out and then the professor pay
kind of looks at him for a second does
this little riddle and then takes his
mask off and it's Damian Wayne and so
it's kinda like okay game Ian looks at
him and then walks away and Batman's
just left there this thing is a descent
into madness it's absolutely insane but
that's what's so cool is because this
this little bit of a story this is you
know the really the second part of like
this nightmares arc to wall it does seem
kind of bonkers and it does seem to seem
crazy it really is kind of like the
nature of Batman encapsulated right
because Batman is technically a crazy
guy what human being would of sound mind
of like clear in sound mind would say my
city's gone to pot I know what'll fix it
I will dress as a bat and beat up people
in the middle of the night that will fix
everything like like who what rational
human being would think that right I
mean that's crazy talk
but like you expect that from a guy who
is in effect crazy and that's why I say
the Batman like this story in particular
like really hits the nature of Batman on
the head because Batman's a crazy person
living in a crazy city and it's one of
those arguments where is it's kind of
like you can't actually defeat someone
like if an enemy is bad enough you can
never truly defeat them unless you
become as bad as them otherwise again
you're only ever a half-measure
you're only ever kind of like keeping
them at bay for a short amount of time
but the reality is that like there are
some foes out there there are some
enemies out there the only way you can
ever really defeat them is to just kill
it to to eliminate them entirely it's
the only way to keep the world safe from
them otherwise they will keep coming
back over and over and over and over
again I mean after all if Batman was a
successful hero there would be no Joker
there would be no two-face there would
be no penguin there'd be no Riddler
there'd be no professor Pig there'd be
no poison ivy presumably no Catwoman
like there'd be none of those none of
those villains that were out there
because that would have dealt with him
right off the bat and that's kind of the
funny thing is Batman sort of fights
with himself right he's kind of like you
know I need to take the high ground well
Batman the high ground don't work it
doesn't work in this bin this instance
because if it did you would have been
successful but it doesn't and so you're
not and so it's it's it's it's kind of
funny that's one of the things I always
sort of found weird about Batman is like
how many chances are you gonna give to
people like how many instances are you
going to kind of like sacrifice innocent
people because you really believe that
that villain could be rehabilitated
there kind of has to be a cutoff point
where you say okay fine we
giving you enough chances now you got to
go like we're just gonna cut your head
off and be done with it right even then
the Joker would still find some way to
return I have no idea but would that be
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end I've rambled long enough if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later purse
[Music]